hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg and my name is Anne woods and woods
is here today
Sharan and woods I met her at my home
actually she's my new roommate and she I
came onto her way too strong and now
she's just a roommate right absolutely
and but the great thing about this deal
is I get free beer whenever I want so
that's the great thing about it she goes
back to a room and then has sex with a
guy yeah this apartments the apartments
just filled with jealousy Nancy's taking
the jealousy gesture this is a horror
short film first person requests this
while yo crazy Joe Joe
oh one says hey Greg you have to react
to gesture short horror film it's pretty
good
well Anne and I will be the judge
generally good night okay we'll see be
ready and that's a [ __ ] what I'm hoping
this isn't too scary
I hope they die I hope they don't nice
they look
remember this was shot
if it gets really scary I'm ice cream
good reaction cry I don't know
like
public park
always goes down in the public parking
lot
all right
Kaiba
thank you
[Laughter]
why would you stop
those very good thank you
look very nice
what look
I I work on home
sorry
thank you have a nice night
magic
cool shot
[Music]
Oh
that's sweet
[Music]
what what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why would you fall
[Music]
[Music]
what
you didn't see her at all not at all yo
bro you mind moving out of the way go
help him
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
tie the shoe
[Music]
there's some great shots
[Music]
hahaha that'll undo it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's him
wait no self hey those guys
[Music]
but but not them it's cuz they have a
costume and they are celebrating this is
what happens if you don't work don't
celebrate Halloween
what Wow another 10 minutes Wow I that
did not seem like a full 10 that seems
so much shorter yes and like half the
light so I feel like that's a good
indication of how enticing it was the
entire way yeah definitely
regionals score there was it seemed like
I had like some throwback vibes to some
slasher films at the same time it wasn't
a slasher story guys slowly getting
tortured into having some type of
costume yeah I don't know what happened
to him though where to get vanished you
and I thought I thought that maybe who's
being inducted into almost like a
vampire
jester dude had a mask on and then I
thought what's gonna happen is that he
put him asked on the the other dude and
then he was gonna like become part of
his what's a jester cult or whatever
what's a jester a gesture like a like a
joker Oh like the Kings jester so what
he was doing was a jester I thought it
was a play on like gesture like Gurt
like oh here's a gesture from Halloween
like you can't even the car he was well
I thought it was really well done I
thought there's some great shots in
there as one of those things were like
if they have probably just a little bit
more money only thing I could have
improved probably was like the sound at
times but other than the sound being I
feel like when it comes to like student
I don't know what the word is beginner
amateur filmmaking or let maybe novice
much more fancy when it comes to this
level of filmmaking I know the sound is
the hardest thing to get down to make
sure that's like perfect yep is that's
expensive to hire people for that and
it's also like a lot of work so other
than the sound at times being off
everything about it was really well
composed the acting was for the most
part pretty good yeah the guy at times I
was wondering why he wasn't just ever
screaming 4gl for help right sounds like
you're in a public area with her other
people walking around this besides the
one car I mean what kind of horror
freaks you out the most when I'm not
able to see the thing that I'm scared of
okay
like not knowing I think that's what
scares any of us okay okay
for me it's any yeah for me it's like
supernatural stuff mmm-hmm yeah exactly
yeah like supernatural furniture some
people get scared of like oh Michael
Mayer says he can really kill you it's a
real gun but but for me it's like stuff
like this can freak me out because I'm
like I don't know all the rules yeah I
agree with you on the sound editing
because like it firt the only the only
time that it really that I really
noticed it was at the very beginning
with the with the buzzing of the the
light yeah it was a been some sort of
street lamp or something so I so maybe
that was added in but I feel like you
there could have been a perhaps but
again it's like it's hard to filter that
kind of stuff out not that I've ever
done
sound editing myself but just talking to
something yeah like the right equipment
and everything like that the shots are
really cool I really like I mean it
looks like there's some coloring done
mm-hmm yeah so kind of like color tint
done to the framing
yeah which is pretty cool yeah
so really cool the costumes were yeah
like all on point but again yeah I was
like why don't think you just as I was
getting during I was like go just like
walk like yes yes dude is creepy
please just try to get some helmets some
ways like the doing part of it that I I
felt was missing a little bit like geez
so weird shit's happening you scream for
help during a public place or on the
flip side if it had shown something that
was so mesmerizing about the gesture or
or something that like he had some sort
of hold over him right even if it was
just like a moment of it it didn't you
know doesn't have to be something that's
like outlandish or like now I have your
brain you know yeah just something that
could have lent to make it speaking a
good sound I made sure the leaf blowers
outside we're happening right now to
make sure I can give you guys a good
example of an awesome sound work you're
welcome we did that we did that on
purpose
it's it's great background noise add
more life scenes getting louder yeah
they're getting closer
no matter where I move you can't escape
people from the outside
[Laughter]
oh the scene that I thought was really
well acted was their first scene
together with it with the guy and the
gesture and there and he's like showing
him the candy and the cards and the way
he was like reacting and responding I
thought that was a good level of like
suspicious worried but be nice and
polite like right I felt like that scene
he had a good that actor had a good
balance of how to react to all that
right it's like it's it seems very
believable even though the rules were a
little yeah totally I mean you got the
invisible visibility cloak sure you you
can remind me of just nail the Greg I
he'll tell me
I remember Amy Ryan in the office yeah
that's awesome
like you have a personality it's very
polite and very like hardworking and
kind but then you get like really goofy
oh my god that's probably the best
person I've ever been yeah that's how I
figure out oh yeah the invisibility
cloak part was really cool too that was
really cool
I didn't yeah I didn't actually expect
that I was right about that like I
wasn't like oh obviously it's gonna be I
was just like where did he go
yeah I don't know where he went I didn't
understand what the whole thing with the
guy hitting him was like with that it's
the stranger at the car Oh like was that
as actual do where the car was just like
the gesture dude it's a magical trick
with a car coming by because he looked
up and then it was him there right and
it was the guy was there because do you
see what you just didn't give a [ __ ]
when he hit him right exactly and I
wonder this is something that I have a
challenge with in writing sometimes is
that I want to add you know something
creepy I'm like oh cool I have like a
really creepy inspiration or like a
horror inspiration I'm just like okay
cool like I'll write that down but then
later I go back and like oh but it
doesn't have like a foundation
underneath it for the reason that it's
there and I feel like this be a little
bit more of a foundation for a reason of
why that's there that's the way way to
analyze your work a common thing in
horror films were I get that that was
creepy yeah but now the film's done this
doesn't make any sense why this scene
was there you're like oh boy I got the
effect that I think the filmmaker was
going for is to creep me out at the same
time there's got to be it's like it just
adds depth once there's a meaning yeah
it actually makes sense
yeah to though but everything set up
because yeah I wonder where he took the
guy he probably took him too
this is the first video I've ever filmed
with the leaf blowers right outside
that's so loud there I'm like up here on
the apartment and they're like way at
the bottom I'm up here on the apartment
and they're like they're like the bottom
of the hey man how do I have like three
slices it's yeah did you think the
gesture was sexy no I've had a jester
mask you mean you wouldn't be into me
then no it wasn't it was two also I knew
that it was a horror film so I wasn't
gonna be like cute so you didn't think
it was sexy at all no man he was just he
was he was just weird and I just wanted
to make fun of him so they seem less
scary yeah that that's an ITT I make fun
of stuff in Oregon well yeah I mean I
guess you got a dress up on Halloween
you got I gotta be something on
Halloween that is the moral of the story
do not die what are you gonna be for
Halloween oh my god that's such a good
idea I don't know I've been wanting to
be [ __ ] nurse [ __ ] Wonder Woman no
I've been wanting to be to be just wave
or Garth actually I think I can be I
can't see you being [ __ ] it's exactly
tumor board not look I've had it my
affair
sheriff actually been with us well I
guess they're not gonna stop anytime
soon
I guess I guess not
hey these guys make do entertainment go
subscribe to this channel because that
was a really damn good horror film yeah
it was and they have oh yeah I've got
quite a lot of use to they do yeah 640
thousand views is a lot of views mm-hmm
now we're just saying things we're not
even really whereby any points we
subscribe to the real rejects Anna woods
woods would Instagram did you make fun
or for that name and woods yeah no like
no wood jokes come on I mean no come on
I found myself like that I don't know
right exactly
there's so many other ways I can make
fun of myself no guys there have been
like I'll show you my one I'll show you
my wood I'll take you to the wall okay
all right see see see how I just see how
sorry okay see